Evidently, Tom Holland's a superhero on and
off the big screen.
A new piece published by The Hollywood Reporter
claims that Holland — who has played the
friendly neighborhood hero Spider-Man since
2016's Captain America: Civil War — sprung
into action and carried out some last-minute,
heroic deeds to help bring Spidey back into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In late August 2019, the web-crawler was forced
to swing out of Marvel's movie world when
it was announced that Marvel Studios and Sony
Pictures couldn't come to an agreement on
how to establish new terms of the deal that
allowed Holland's Spider-Man to appear in
the MCU.
Several weeks later, the two studios confirmed
that they returned to the negotiating table
and finally came up with a way to make everyone
happy: Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
will produce a third Spider-Man movie starring
Holland, Marvel's parent company Disney will
receive 25 percent of the profits from said
threequel, and Spider-Man will appear in at
least one more MCU movie.
Cue the collective sigh of relief.
It looks like that doozy of a cliffhanger
will pay off, after all!
"Spider-Man's name… is Peter Parker!"
"What the f—"
Striking the right revenue split apparently
played a huge part in getting Marvel, Disney,
and Sony executives back on the same page
regarding their respective involvement in
the Spider-Man film series.
What was also a major deciding factor in sealing
the new Spidey deal was Holland himself.
According to sources close to THR, Holland,
quote, "made multiple appeals" to Walt Disney
Company CEO Bob Iger and contacted Sony Pictures
chairman Tom Rothman on numerous occasions
to help facilitate a reconciliation between
the two parties.
The fact that Holland is set to star in another
Sony project — the forthcoming film adaptation
of the Uncharted video game series — probably
didn't hurt.
It was certainly admirable of Holland to get
in touch with Iger and Rothman and assist
in bringing the two opposing studios to a
resolution.
It's also very much something Spider-Man would
do: a scrappy, somewhat unlikely hero pulling
himself out of the rubble to do the right
thing.
As heart-warming and heroic as Holland's reported
appeals were, however, they aren't surprising
when taking a look at how he responded to
the Sony-Marvel split in the first place.
The first time Holland spoke about Spider-Man
leaving the MCU was during D23 Expo on Saturday,
August 24 — several days after the shocking
news dropped.
Holland's silence — and his alarmingly nonchalant
behavior on social media — was cause for
concern.
Finally, when he piped up, he said exactly
the right thing.
He told fans:
"It's been a crazy week, but I want you to
know I am grateful from the bottom of my heart,
and I love you 3,000."
As time went on and Marvel and Sony showed
no signs of getting back together for another
Spider-Man flick, Holland maintained a diplomatic,
optimistic attitude that never wavered.
He refused to align himself with one studio
over the other — even with millions of fans
pulling him in different directions — and
held his head high.
The 23-year-old actor noted that Marvel helped
make his dreams come true, and that he had,
quote, "five amazing years" working under
the House of Heroes, but knew that the future
of Spider-Man would be, quote, "equally as
awesome and amazing" and that Sony would,
quote, "find new ways to make it even cooler."
Holland later assured his adoring fans that
Sony would do right by Spider-Man even without
Marvel involved.
He told GQ's Zach Baron:
"Sony has also been really good to me, and
the global success of Spider-Man: Far From
Home is a real testament to their support,
skill and commitment.
The legacy and future of Spidey rests in Sony's
safe hands.
I really am nothing but grateful."
See where we're going with all this?
Tom Holland truly is the definition of a stand-up
guy, so it should come as no surprise that
he went out of his way to get in touch with
Disney's Bob Iger and Sony's Tom Rothman to
figure out a way to end the fighting, get
fans to smile again, and bring fat stacks
of cash to both studios' bank accounts with
a third Spider-Man movie and another MCU collaboration.
With great power comes great responsibility,
and Holland used his for good — just like
Spider-Man would.
"When you can do the things that I can, but
you don't, and then the bad things happen...
they happen because of you."
Fans can catch Holland back in the Spidey
suit for the yet-untitled third Spider-Man
film, set to launch in theaters on July 16,
2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.